[Music]
how would i describe the vibe of cascade
on a sunday night
you would see 500 800 000 people in the
facility
you have this culture that has been
created and it's just growing out of
control
and you don't really experience that
anywhere else but here
[Music]
when desegregation began in the late 50s
and early 60s
some roller rink owners did not take
kindly to it they decided to create
themed nights specifically targeted
towards african americans
if black roller skaters made an
appearance on other days of the week
they found themselves unwelcome
but those nights
ended up turning into something all of
their own i didn't realize the impact
that a roller skating rink has on a
community
they would just open up a skating rink
and boy people came and it was always
crowded so all of those things came
together to really blow roller skating
up
here is what so many people gravitate to
and i didn't realize until i actually
built cascade
[Applause]
[Music]
i don't know where i would be without
roller skating it saved me
so sunday nights at cascade is amazing
because of the energy
[Music]
we come you got your crews you got your
single skaters you got your couples and
you just it's time to show out it's the
real atlanta culture and you can kind of
see
the style that atlanta does
[Music]
we call it riding in atlanta it's just a
really cool like you ride the beat and
they go fast so we wear the low carrera
skates with the big speed wheels and you
see the guys doing the routines and
there are a couple of original groups
that still skate and they got the style
started the roller skating culture is
like a underground family we have a
facebook we have a skateboard it's kind
of addictive it's our drug of choice and
it's a non-stop party on wheels so
that's kind of how i fell in love with
it
even on a sunday night we have people
that will tell you they've been skating
here since they were eight years old
it's kind of like the mom
the dad
the
teenager the little brother like and
they all are skating
it's just a lifestyle that when you come
here you get the energy of all different
types of people all different types of
walk but when they come here they're
skaters
so all those things kind of bundle up
into this building that makes this place
to me what the community would miss if
this skatering wasn't here that's why
it's been here for so long it's still
thriving you make it about the community
everything else just kind of falls into
place
[Music]
you